[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au faux pas trop
d'accord mon gros nounours montre dans
le livre et je vais le raconter
d'histoires et hop
mon dieu patron j'oubliais monde seul tu
es trop pressé nounours deux cales
bourse
là on le shell
[Musique]
on soit mais au fond ce mois nounours ah
qu'est ce que tu nous est apportée peux
tu vois bien que c'est un livre d'imagés
les enfants nicole là je me dis voilà
comme vous avez été très sage je vais
vous montrer un bon livre d'image et
notre ami le marchand de sable va vous
en raconter l'histoire ce cas là c'est
l'histoire de notre ami l'enjeu suffit
de son âne en vous autres dans le jardin
du petit chinois
il n'y a plus de cerises il n'y a plus
de fleurs il n'y a plus de légumes tout
est recouvert de neige et youtube et
tous les autres patients ils sont partis
dans des pays plus chaud il ne reste
plus plus de grands roseaux au bord de
la rivière rien tu dois avoir froid non
il habite avec yang chu dans sa maison
bien au chaud et un jour bien que fut
choisi le plus beau roseaux et le
cueille et le soir assis au coin du feu
avec son ami en il taille de dans un
pipeau qu'est ce que c'est un pipeau que
tu pètes me collard dit non je sais moi
c'est avec son pipeau que mon ami le
marchand de sable joue sa bluesy
mais oui bien que chu souffle dans son
pipeau tout neuf et il en sort une
musique merveilleuse et ans aime
beaucoup écouter cette musique est pour
lui faire plaisir
le petit chinois jouent pendant des
heures puis ils vont se coucher tous
contents mais gros vilain qui n'habite
pas très loin a entendu cette belle
musique et il s'est approché de la
maison et dès que yang chu est endormi
ils entrent sans faire de bruit prend le
pipeau et se sauvant ce gros village
qu'elle gère mais on l'a entendu ou au
liant que tu fus se lève prend son bâton
sur la tête à gros vilain où se finit en
chute
je te promets que je ne recommencerai
plus 10 celui ci qui sait bien qu'il est
vilain et il part se cacher tout honteux
mais yang chu est très heureux d'avoir
retrouvé son précieux pipeau grâce à y
en ait pour le remercier tous les soirs
au coin du feu
il lui joue du pipeau magro vilaine
recommande toujours à faire de bêtise
n'est pas très malin
youpi je rattrape toujours le chant sont
toujours punis belge petit allons
l'histoire
qu'elle était jolie cette histoire merci
petit marchand de sable allons les
petits ou doudou
[Musique]
bon
bonne nuit mon petit ange la jute à la
lune at home
[Musique]
connu une hausse à demain connu nicolas
venu pas prenait alors les enfants
l'histoire vous a plu oui tant mieux si
vous êtes bien sage
on vous en racontera d'autres
et maintenant allez vite vous coucher
[Musique]
allons en route mon cher nounours bonnut
les enfants faites de beaux rêves
à demain
fait brewers un peu
[Musique]